now let's help our users find our app
and get some organic traffic for free we
can do this by search engine
optimization or SEO for short we can
also do the same thing in the App Store
which is called App Store optimization
ASO how does it work the search engine
uses an algorithm the scans all of the
information on the web and for F stores
the algorithm scans all of the
information in all listings of the App
Store the algorithm will decide what is
the most relevant based on the content
of your site and the most relevant sites
and apps will appear at the top of the
results but under the peda as of course
let's talk about some of the techniques
you can use for SEO and ASO